In 1993 comedy Groundhog Day starring
Bill Murray has always been a favorite of
mine.
If you'd asked a younger version of me
what the movie was about and I would've
said groundhog day is a movie about a
cynical's selfish man who must relive the
same day over and over again
until he learns to care for the people
around him and in so doing becomes a
better person.
It's hard down there at the bottom today.
I think I described the
plot somewhat differently.
I'd say groundhog day is a movie about a
cynical selfish man who must relive the
same day over and over again until he's
able to learn everything there is to
know about his coworker and
despite her repeated rejections,
use that information to eventually
make her fall in love with him.
Well, both plot summaries
are technically accurate.
What I missed as a younger man was an
understanding of how movies often presents
stalker like behavior as a harmless or
endearing part of romantic courtship.
How did you do that?
I know your face so well.
I could have done it with my eyes closed.
One Popular Romance Trope in particular
provides the foundation for the plot of
groundhog day.
I call that trope stocking for love.
I would really appreciate it
if you would just go away.
If you've spent any time at all going
to the movies or watching television,
then you're probably already familiar with
this romance formula and how it works.
Excuse me. Have you seen the Feminine
Mystique? I've lost my coffee.
What are you doing here? I heard
there was a poetry. You're so Jami.
Wholesome,
unwelcome.
Our hero is typically a nice guy who
doesn't quite fit the Hollywood ideal of
manhood and who for a variety of reasons,
hasn't found love.
One day he happens upon a very special
woman and instantly becomes infatuated
with her.
Time slows down,
the music swells and the camera zooms in.
These audio visual cues are designed to
communicate to us the audience that this
is true love,
but wait,
there's just one small problem.
I always wondered if I could a snag your
cell phone number or your email before
you left. I don't think so, Mike.
She doesn't return his feelings.
Maybe she's dating someone else.
Maybe she's already rejected him.
Maybe she doesn't even know he exists
or maybe she's just not interested.
What's a nice guy to do when
faced with such a dilemma? Well,
he's certainly not going to give
up. No, he'll do whatever it takes.
This is true love after all or it will
be once he convinces this woman to love
him back
and so to that end,
our hero proceeds to spy on her pastor
her and otherwise manipulate her until he
finally manages to wear down her defenses
and she agrees to go out with him.
Yes. Will you leave? This is
my job. 8:00 PM tomorrow. Fine,
fine,
fine.
As a media convention, stocking for
love can be traced all the way back.
The classic Hollywood
got this cabinet one
and it's a mainstay of both
Bollywood and European cinema.
Even though stocking for love
is most commonly associated
with romantic comedies,
what's often overlooked is the
tropes prominence in other genres.
Have you been following me,
especially superhero stories.
I knew it
just once a day.
Sometimes
sometimes more.
In these narratives,
a man's obsessive coercive or stalker
like behavior is framed as an expression
of his love and devotion.
If I really have it saw it,
I'll ride by her house,
my bike, I'll do it like,
like a hundred times in a day.
It's really, it's intense.
And even if the woman in
question is initially upset
or annoyed by his obsessive
attention, his actions are
inevitably framed as a compliment.
I don't really know you that well,
but you seem like a fine person and I
want you to know that I'm flattered by all
this.
The trend in more recent media is
to lamp shade, romantic stalking,
lamb shading is when writers directly
acknowledge immediate trope were cliche in
the dialogue itself.
Hi, Max. I'm Dustin and Lucas. Yeah,
I know the stalkers.
But remember that acknowledgement alone
isn't the same thing as criticism or
subversion. So for example, in the
popular Netflix series, stranger things,
Max calls out Lucas's
stalker like behavior.
What is the shift? Stalker?
Sorry, I just needed a safe place,
a safe place to what?
Be Creepy.
But in the end, Lucas still gets
the girl even after he stalks her,
tricks her and traps her
alone in a room with him.
No. On one level, the popularity
of this trope is understandable.
Most people want to
feel like we're special,
like we're worthy of romantic
attention from someone we like.
And most people really want to believe
in the idea of love at first sight.
But while it may be nice to imagine
sweeping your crush off their feet,
the truth is that much of the behavior
we see in these movies could very easily
land you in jail.
Did you get in here? I
like watching you sleep. So
it's kind of fascinating to me.
In the real world, stalking
isn't romantic. In fact,
it's a crime.
And beyond the legal implications,
stocking can also have a serious
emotional effect on the victims
leading to anxiety,
paranoia, depression. Yes,
me or even PTSD.
I'm sorry, did I scare you?
I'm just a little on it.
Stalking encompasses a
wide range of behaviors,
including following someone
repeated unwelcomed communication,
showing up at a person's workplace,
residents or school uninvited.
Are you sure about this, sir? We might
have some constitutional issues here.
Patriot Act,
as well as spying on tracking
or monitoring an individual,
either online or offline.
Vr have these amazing Isaiah.
This is the type of conduct that we
expect from the villain in a horror movie,
but pop culture,
media consistently frames each and every
one of these behaviors as something
romantic, curvy. How are you?
I'm obsessed.
Thank you very much.
Now I should say that occasionally the
roles are reversed and we see a woman's
stocking a man,
and we'll talk about that in a minute,
but since men are most often the ones
who perpetrate this kind of behavior,
I want to focus on what this
trope communicates about
men, masculinity and love.
The specific circumstances and severity
of the stalking behavior will vary from
story to story.
What are you doing here?
Well, I tried to call, but
how did you get my address?
The library.
But the bottom line here is that these
male characters all refuse to respect
women's boundaries,
women's personal space or women's privacy.
I have a boyfriend.
I'm sorry.
Make it have a boyfriend so you
can get rid of me. No, I'm not.
What's his name?
Then they don't listen to women's words.
I brought you flowers and they ignore
all signals of disinterest or rejection.
Why don't I just put these
in the same water? In short,
they refuse to take no for an answer.
Stocking for love usually culminates
in some sort of grand romantic gesture.
These are public spectacles that are
designed to demonstrate the depth and
intensity of our heroes,
feelings for the woman of his dreams.
Right.
Bye.
Now, of course, romantic gestures
are not always troubling.
If two people are already
in a relationship or if
their feelings have been
openly communicated,
then it can be really sweet.
I thought this was a good
idea and it feels kind of,
it feels a little stupid and
depending on the context,
it might be okay to humbly and
privately ask for a second chance.
As we saw in the recent Romcom, the
big sick, what do you take me back?
But that's not how it typically
happens in Hollywood. In most movies,
grand romantic gestures are designed to
be elaborate and bushes and bushes that
put women on the spot in
a very public way. Yo,
just too good to be true.
Can't take my eyes off of you.
There's an undercurrent of coersion
running through these schemes because they
set up situations where the woman
in question will appear callous.
We're heartless if she rejects the guy
again after he's gone through all the
trouble of pulling off
his elaborate stunt.
Since these are movies
we're talking about,
filmmakers usually give us a window into
the hidden feelings of each character.
This means that we as the audience have
access to information that the male
suitor doesn't.
Information that makes us more willing
to overlook his intrusive behavior.
So for instance, in the classic
1989 Teen Romance, say anything,
we know that Diane broke up with Lloyd
because of pressure from her father.
Hello, but we also know that
she secretly wants him back.
That piece of insight or information
makes this iconic scene seemed like a
touching gesture.
The problem is that Lloyd doesn't
know how she's feeling at this point.
He only knows two things.
First that she explicitly told him
she didn't want to see or talk to him.
And second that she's ignored his
many phone calls after the breakup.
Given these two pieces of information,
Lloyd decides it's a good idea to show
up at her father's house and blast Peter
Gabriel's in your eyes
through her bedroom window.
A song that has significance because it
was what they listened to when they were
having sex for the first time.
Imagine an ex lover pulling a stunt like
that after you've broken up with them
and told them to stay away from you.
Nothing about it would be romantic.
It would be creepy in the extreme and
probably cause for calling the cops.
Oh,
hi.
The now infamous sign guy from love.
Actually
it's Carol saying is
professors his love for the woman.
He's been obsessive.
Lee videotaping and who also happens
to be the new wife of his best friend.
Yeah,
inexplicably sign guy is rewarded for
his creepy and deeply inappropriate
behavior with a kiss.
Romantic stocking at its core
isn't really about love at all.
It's extremely selfish behavior because
it's all about the stalkers own personal
feelings. Any potential discomfort, fear,
or embarrassment on the part of the
stockers target is rarely ever considered.
Behold, Jessica Riley,
you are my soul mate.
The love of my life.
I have marked myself for the scarlet Jae,
Jessica Ravi gets out from there.
The notebook offers an added
layer of emotional manipulation.
It's the romantic gesture.
What
will you leave me?
No choice then
Ryan Gosling's character not only refuses
to take no for an answer when I ask
you one more time,
he threatens to kill himself.
If his love interest
doesn't agree to a date,
they'll in the head slipper. Okay.
Okay, fine. I'll go out with you.
I'll do me any favors.
In the critically acclaimed dead poet's
society knocks overstreets decision to
persistently pursue a young woman from
a different school who he doesn't know
and who already has a boyfriend is framed
by the film as his car pay DM moment,
Tom Tom.
Yet
when he kisses her while
she's passed out at a party,
it's not depicted as assault.
Instead,
his actions are represented as overcoming
his self doubt and learning to live
life to the fullest
knocks his character.
Arc is part of a pattern in
Hollywood coming of age stories,
a pattern where confidence building
for boys often comes at the expense of
women's boundaries and
women's personal autonomy.
Movies have taught us
that never giving up is one of
the most admirable traits of all,
especially for men. I know how I can
get to her. What I know how I can get.
Declare, John, you got to drop this thing.
I can't do this anymore with you. Okay.
It's been several months and you
haven't heard anything from her.
She hasn't returned your phone calls.
She's never responded
to one of your letters.
She didn't respond to the candy gram.
Right.
I think it's very obvious at this juncture
that she just flat out does not want
to see. Yeah, I disagree.
Well, it's certainly true
that determination can
be a very positive thing.
That's only the case when it doesn't
ignore the desires of other people or end
up violating someone else's privacy.
How are you now she's in here some
costumes. Stocking the Fox stuff.
Sometimes writers attempt to justify
stocking behavior by framing it as
necessary to keep women safe from the
dangers posed by other men in these kinds
of stories,
protecting women from attacks by strangers
is depicted as a selfless gesture.
Get in the car
a gesture that proves a man's
love as well as his manhood.
Did you follow me?
Oh,
I feel very protective of you.
Stocking for protection. Storylines are
troubling for a whole host of reasons,
but chief among them is the fact that
regardless of the intentions behind it,
stocking does not make women feel safer.
You know, being stocked isn't
really a big turn on for girls
counter to what television
has led us to believe.
Women are far more likely to be assaulted
by men they already know then by
strangers in dark alleys.
Stocking for love isn't framed as
something worthy of genuine concern.
It's depicted as just a temporary
lapse in judgment fueled by passionate
feelings.
How could you do that,
ted?
How could you have some guy
you don't even know spy on me?
In some instances the romantic stocker
might confess or apologize once he's
caught,
but rarely are there any lasting
negative impacts or meaningful forms of
atonement. I did it because I
never stopped thinking about you.
You are so infuriating.
If he comes clean,
his transgressions are quickly
forgiven and in most cases,
his manipulative ploys to spend time with
her under false pretenses have already
worked their magic and
proven that he's Mr. Right?
The message is clear.
Anything can be overlooked as long
as it's done in the name of love.
A man's deception is lies.
His trickery is none of that disqualifies
him from a romantic relationship and
even if the two don't
get together in the end,
he's still shown to be a nice guy and
he's often given a consolation prize.
Maybe it's a kiss,
maybe it's naked photos or
maybe it's a different woman.
In reality,
of course,
the willingness to flagrantly violate
someone else's space and someone else's
privacy is a major red flag.
It's behavior connected to deep seated
issues of control and extreme levels of
entitlement.
When the gender roles are reversed and
we see a female character stocking a man,
her actions are typically portrayed as
manic or unbalanced instead of endearing.
I did not move here because of Josh
because that would be crazy and I am not
crazy.
This is basically the premise for the
TV show. Crazy ex girlfriend. Oh my God.
I mean it's right there in the
title. Oh my God. No, I'm
not crazy. I'm not crazy.
Not Crazy. I'm not crazy. Oh
my God. Oh my God. I'm crazy.
You hear me? You're not
crazy. You're in love
stories in which women stock men are
part of a double standard in Hollywood.
This guy here, oh, you know what?
She just left because straight male
characters almost never find unwanted
affections. Charming or romantic. Sorry.
Okay.
Oh God,
I made eye contact.
I'm in no way suggesting that stocking
behavior is okay when it's done by a
woman.
It's absolutely not.
But I do think it's important to note
that the social and cultural implications
are different.
When media shows women stocking men,
statistics show that women are more likely
to be the victims of stalking and men
are more likely to be the perpetrators.
That coupled with the fact that women are
also far more likely to be the targets
of sexual violence or domestic abuse
means that women have good reason to be
fearful of men who intrude on their lives.
Media employing the stocking for love
trope has been shown to have negative
effects on people's attitudes and
expectations when it comes to courtship,
Romance,
and love in the real world.
There you go again, putting your
hand in places it doesn't belong.
Movies like those we've been discussing
in this video served to reinforce a
variety of harmful myths about romance.
You want to get back together.
Is that it?
These include the idea that women
don't really know what they want.
That stocking like behaviors are
justified when love is on the line
and that stalking victims
are just playing hard to get.
Studies have also found that watching
media where stalkers are depicted as
dangerous or terrifying,
has the opposite effect and can decrease
people's belief in myths about romantic
stalking.
Contrary to what movies tell us,
attraction is not the same thing as love.
You don't know me,
but my name is Edward Blum and I love you.
Neither is infatuation or obsession,
both of which Hollywood
consistently confuses for true love.
Oh,
romantic love is mutual and reciprocal.
It's an exchange between people and
unless your partner develops a form of
dementia,
romantic love is not something that only
one person can feel towards another.
There's no reason why Hollywood can't
tell love stories where all parties
involved treat each other with respect.
Even within the realm of mutual fact,
there are countless possibilities for
quirky or humorous scenarios. Well,
she had a boyfriend in the house.
Nice boy. Oh No, no.
The obstacles to romance can
come in any number of forms.
Things like family disapproval or
illness or geographic location,
just to name a few.
There's no reason why the central conflict
in a romance story needs to involve
stalking behavior
and honestly,
making people feel unsafe is a terrible,
terrible way to show you care about them.
Valley,
you want to ride the Ferris wheel. If you
ask someone out and they're interested,
great, right? But if they
say they're not interested,
it's not your job to test them on or to
try to figure out if maybe they're just
playing hard to get,
and rejection is not an invitation to
try to coerce them into changing their
minds.
What do you take me back?
Sure.
Rejection doesn't feel good.
It just feels totally different
now and I can't do that again.
But the respectful thing to do is to
gracefully accept no for an answer.
Do you understand? Okay. Okay.
Thanks for watching these videos take
an enormous amount of time to produce,
especially for just one person.
So if you'd like to see more,
please consider going over to Patrion
and helping to fund the project there.
There's also a link to paypal
in the description below.
Over the next several months, we'll be
talking more about masculinity, love,
and the media,
including a disturbingly popular action
movie trope called abduction for love.
Wow.